[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce lundi est 10
juillet le stade philippe cousteau de la
verrière réquisitionnée par l'état pour
accueillir des migrants après le
démantèlement de plusieurs campements à
paris un choix qui fait réagir les
politiques locaux entre soutien et
dénonciation du manque de concertation
sébastien lecornu secrétaire d'état à la
transition écologique s'est rendu à jouy
en josas l'ancien président du conseil
départemental de l'eure a notamment
salué le travail effectué par la
municipalité sur la question écologique
enfin sensations garanties ce week-end
au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la structure
proposer des initiations cyclisme sur
piste au bmx pour les plus courageux au
portage à suivre à la fin de ce journal
plus d'une centaine de migrants sont
installés à la verrière depuis vendredi
un dispositif d'hébergement d'urgence a
été mise en place au parc sportif
philippe cousteau réquisitionnées par la
préfecture une opération de mise en
sécurité pour ces migrants qui viennent
de campements parisien le stade est
mobilisée jusqu'au 7 août
un accueil temporaire qui vise à les
orienter vers des centres d'accueil plus
adapté ensuite dans un communiqué la
maire de la ville elie du tueur a
rappelé la nécessité d'urgence
humanitaire de la situation elle demande
aussi de garder une attitude
bienveillante et respectueuse de nos
valeurs républicaines
on les écoute on a toujours dit sur la
verrière qu'on était prêt à prendre
notre part de responsabilité dans
l'accueil des migrants pour qu'ils
trouvent
une place digne et respectueuse la
police nationale la police municipale
les associations les agents de sécurité
tout le monde et regarde surveille les
regards et nous mêmes on y est tous les
jours on a fermé le parc aussi pour des
raisons de sécurité de tranquillité et
cette situation n'est pas du goût de
tous nicolas dainville conseiller
municipal de droite regrette lui
l'absence de concertation avec les élus
la préfecture et l'état maître la mairie
devant le fait accompli que on
réquisitionne un espace qui soit pas
adapté pour ce genre de situation
j'aurais préféré que ce soit sur la base
du volontariat avec des communes qui
soit spontanément volontaires et qui est
une compensation financière
je pense que les habitants sont
solidaires ce qui est plutôt une bonne
chose mais ils ont vraiment besoin de
voix l'ado clarté transparence est tenu
informé les riverains ont besoin d'être
rassurés et pour être tout à fait
complet sur le sujet sachez que depuis
samedi une collecte d'urgence est menée
par l'association enfants du petit pays
les habitants peuvent ainsi faire des
dons de vêtements pour hommes de
nourriture ou de produits d'hygiène
trois points de collecte sont installés
à l'arrière et notamment à la mairie
plus d'informations sur le site de la
verrière dans le reste de l'actualité
ces images qui viennent de tout juste de
nous parvenir du déplacement dans les
yvelines de deux ministres nicolas hulot
et stéphane travert respectivement
ministre de la transition écologique et
de l'agriculture ils sont en visite sur
le centre de l'inra à versailles et
l'inra le premier institut de recherche
agronomique en europe et le deuxième au
monde
autre déplacement ministériel c'était
samedi cette fois-ci sébastien lecornu
le secrétaire d'état à la transition
écologique et solidaire s'est rendu lui
à jouy en josas jouy en josas pour
saluer notamment la politique
environnementale engagée par la ville
qui s'est engagé à être autonome en
énergie d'ici à quarante ans reportages
sur des images de nicolas d'andré sous
le soleil les manches de chemise relever
face au jardin partagé le secrétaire
d'état est venu
distribuer les bons points pour ce
déplacement la ville de jouy en josas
fait figure d'exemple sur les
problématiques environnementales et dans
sa collaboration avec l'état un
partenariat qui a permis notamment le
financement de plusieurs projets comme
la rénovation énergétique d'un groupe
scolaire pour près de 400000 euros
voyez ce qui est fait sur la lutte
contre le gaspillage alimentaire dans
les écoles dans les collèges moi c'est
quelque chose qui nous tient
extrêmement à coeur les politiques sur
l'écomobilité sur la nouvelle manière de
se déplacer en ville et sur les jardins
partagés
bref ici ou lis une véritable
laboratoire vitrine de toutes les bonnes
pratiques qu'on a envie de voir
pour une ville durable dans le pays
demain être d'ici 40 ans jouy en josas
ambitionne d'être autonome en énergie
pour y parvenir la ville agit sur la
consommation des bâtiments les
circulations douces ou encore le
traitement des déchets une démarche
éco-responsable dont bénéficieront
principalement les nouvelles générations
c'est vital pour nos enfants et j'étais
très content aujourd'hui d'avoir des des
petits conseillers municipaux du conseil
municipal des jeunes
ce sont eux qui vont hériter de la
politique qu'on lance aujourd'hui et les
résultats se sont re qu'il est vivront
donc il est capital pour nos enfants et
petits-enfants d'engager cette politique
avec beaucoup de détermination
le 17 juillet prochain l'état et les
collectivités pourront une nouvelle fois
faire étalage de leur bonne entente
environnementales lors de la conférence
des territoires prévu au sénat d'autres
sujets comme l'exonération de la taxe
d'habitation pour 80% des ménages
risquent de vite mettre à mal cette
complicité et on referme cette page
politique avec la république en marche
qui poursuit sa mue samedi le mouvement
créé par emmanuel macron a organisé sa
première convention nationale
l'occasion de présenter une nouvelle
organisation avec un conseil un bureau
exécutif et des délégués généraux le
tout doit être encore validé par les
adhérents fin juillet cette convention
vous le voyez été animée par le référent
yvelines du mouvement aziz françois
n'diaye dans un tout autre sujet les
gagnants du concours yvelines
environnement sont exposées en ce moment
à la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
au total
ils sont jeunes âgés de 5 à 15 ans ont
été récompensés pour leurs peintures
croquis ou encore mc est le but de ce
concours qui a duré toute l'année
permettre aux jeunes de s'exprimer sur
le sujet de l'écologie l'exposition
prend fin le 3 septembre prochain
les précisions avec haussmann 20 ans et
patrick jacques de dixmude jusqu'au 3
septembre des oeuvres des 800 gagnants
du concours d'yveline environnement sont
exposés à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet on peut y voir des maquettes
ou encore des peintures le thème cette
année était la mare le thème de l'année
passée étaient nos amis les mares car
nous avons pensé qu' à travers les mares
se développait tout un écosystème qu'il
était important de connaître et que sans
doute quelquefois quand on se promène en
forêt on n'est pas très attentif à ce qu
est une mare et j'espère que grâce à ce
travail qui auraient été effectuées on
comprendra tout l'intérêt des marques
dans l'écosystème l'écosystème et
surtout l'écologie le but de ce concours
qui a duré toute l'année d'initier les
élèves âgés entre 5 et 15 ans à ce thème
et surtout de pouvoir s'exprimer
le but est de faire découvrir un thème
qui concerne notre environnement et nous
avons des thèmes extrêmement variés
puisque il ya eu les arbres il ya eu
aussi la question du patrimoine ya eu le
patrimoine bâti ya eu les oiseaux et
après la mare un nouveau concours sera
mis en place l'année prochaine
le thème de celui ci nos amis les
prairies allez à vos cookies on prend
maintenant la direction du vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
structure proposée ce dimanche des
initiations au cyclisme sur piste et au
bmx à des sportifs amateurs reportage
nicolas d'andreï miquel et demi d'euros
si je me ferai pas je tourne la tête
tout simplement d'accord vous avez juste
journée initiation ce dimanche le 9
juillet au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
quarantaine de riders de la petite
course une compétition à pignon fixe
organisée la veille à paris sont venus
tester les boss du stadium de bmx
tout cela sous l'oeil vigilant d'un
coach diplômé d'état moi je mise
beaucoup sur l'équilibré les exercices
sans pédales et après on regarde un
petit peu haut niveau conduite comment
comment les pratiques en arrive à
pédaler parce qu'on est sur une
discipline où faut pédaler tout le temps
de goût donc ça peut poser quelques
problèmes pour certains c'est pas un
sport de cascadeur il faut quand même
être mesuré et contrôlé ce qu'on fait
dont il faut gérer sa vitesse après une
vingtaine de minutes dès ses premières
réactions
en fait j'avais un peu peur au début je
pense est donc plus à me bloquer un peu
et au final quand on voit les autres le
faire on dit qu'on va pas y arriver il
faut essayer une fois et après ça va une
fois la première initiation terminé
place à la piste les riders venus des
quatre coins de la france ont pu
découvrir l'antre du vélodrome nationale
habitué à pratiquer le vélo à pignon
fixe sans frein ces têtes brûlées n'ont
pas eu de mal à dompter les virages à 43
degrés même si j'avais pas fait de piste
avant c'est quand même plus simple on a
quand même la préhension parce qu'on
arrive sur un mur qui est presque droit
et on se demande comment on va réussir à
tenir dessus mais c'est très bien aller
je suis super content que ça donne
vraiment envie d'en faire après on est
vraiment dans un superbe au vélodrome
donc ça encourage encore plus depuis son
lancement en 2015 le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a effectué
plus de 10000 baptême sur piste de la
structure à maurepas à la ville
organisée ce samedi sa première
guinguette dans le quartier du village
destiné aux seniors pour passer un
moment convivial déjeuner champêtre et
danses rythmées étaient au programme
ambiance avec nicolas landry
un boléro pour lancer la guinguette mort
2eme les seniors de la ville ont
enflammé la piste installée pour
l'occasion dans la cour du centre de
loisirs primaire de maurepas village un
après midi de danse et de convivialité
je n'ai pas dansé d'abord parce que
c'est un moment de danse et parce que on
connaît très bien le village est en fait
j'ai toujours parfait je le vois jean
genet voisins j'ai des belles dames et
bien les danses un petit peu seul parce
qu'on écoute n'aime pas danser donc je
crois que je vais pas être accompagnées
donc je vais danser sur un petit peu
folklore on se retrouve tous ensemble
ceux qui partent en vacances on reparle
de nos vacances des petites anecdotes
qu'on a eu des échanges pendant le
déjeuner au menu merguez ou en
douillette accompagné de frites ou de
taboulé une première pour la ville de
mortain l'objectif c'est toujours dans
l'esprit est toujours sur la même ligne
projet intergénérationnel et fling avec
les seniors c'est à dire que au tout au
long de l'après midi va y avoir des
master class avec des jeunes du mille
club pour danser avec nous est née cette
fête permet de rentrer dans la période
estivale avant de partir en vacances
pour certains mort d'asia à magny les
hameaux le coup d'envoi des vacances
d'été a été donné avec le début ce
week-end de la 8e édition de remets tes
tongs pendant une semaine les habitants
vont pouvoir profiter de nombreuses
animations sur le thématique cette année
des transports alternatifs ambiance une
nouvelle fois avec nicolas landry
[Musique]
l'école est finie les vacances d'été
commencent les manies quoi sont invités
à remettre leurs tongs plusieurs
ateliers notamment le bar à jus avec la
possibilité de faire un smoothie sur un
vélo pédaler pour se régaler verdict
après dégustation avec mathis 6 ans j'ai
fait du vélo avec un smoothie pour faire
du souci des bizuths et les smoothies
c'était bon
mes enfants il adore parce qu'il ya
plein d'animations la mobilité
alternative est aussi à l'honneur
balades en poney pour le côté
traditionnel un moyen de transport plus
futuriste avec l'initiation à
l'hoverboard tenir les équilibres avancé
et slalomer des moments passés entre les
parents et les enfants en famille alors
je trouve ses amis aussi
la l'école est terminée donc voilà c'est
copie dûment pied déjà en cale en
profite
l'événement est très sympa en fait c'est
très familial on peut venir avec plein
d'enfants de tout âge
magny les hameaux organise pour la
huitième fois cette manifestation en
collaboration avec une dizaine
d'associations de la commune cet
événement est mis en place pour
permettre aux jeunes maniwaki ont pas
forcément là l'occasion de partir en
vacance de pouvoir s'amuser
le temps d'une semaine autour de plein
d'activités on a des activités pour
toutes les catégories d'âge des murs
d'escaladé un airbag jump avec
possibilité de faire des figures en bmx
ou encore le pique nique du 14 juillet
sont prévus pour le reste de la semaine
près de 2000 personnes sont attendues
pour cette édition c'est la fin de ce 7
8 le journal tous nos reportages sont à
retrouver en replay sur tv soixante dix
huit pour info l'application tv 78
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]